who understands the month of March or
the third of a
month okay my mom's birthday is days
your mom's very polite but she's
pushy she's like tapping excuse me am I
going to as soon as I started channeling
over here she like turned to I think
there's another father figure over here
as well that is deported she's asking
him are we what's going to happen now
did she just like drop us is she going
to talk to us again what does this mean
and then she's tapping me on the
shoulder like excuse me and I I was like
well then show me something to say
something that's so again was someone
had the difficulty breathing or we watch
them take their last breath yes how do
you understand that my mother okay and I
feel like your mom is just like I need
you to stop visualizing what it was like
for me to die I don't want you to think
that I was afraid or that I was scared
she said you know what I was afraid of I
was afraid of leaving you she says and I
know that you didn't want me to let go
and I want to thank you for telling
telling me that it was okay to let go do
you understand that cuz I can feel you
holding her hand do you understand that
was holding her hand and I'm going to
also say this were you not going to do
this today yes cuz she goes Teresa he
was not even going to do this she goes
they had to talk him into it she like
literally I just literally W in this
building I told him to do it shut up and
it was your I know this is the crazy
thing and I literally turned to you was
like your mom's like no no no this is
going to happen for him joking before
this that I was like my mom's going to
push your okay you're going to have to
wa cuz this crazy there is no way that I
would have known that right so now and
and and I don't know if your mom was in
the hospital for a while um or what but
she looked at me she goes and I finally
got my hair done
Teresa oh my God but do you how does
that make sense to you with with the
hair her hair was your color and then oh
she had great hair I guess mom had great
hair and then as she got sicker and
sicker it was gray but she was always a
blonde she's like I finally got my hair
done but these are those little things
of her saying this is how I want you to
remember me and I don't know did you
find clothes in her house that still had
tags on them or something cuz she goes
Teresa I swear I was not a hoarder she
says they found things she had a lot of
clothes with t but still with tags on
them now I'm going to also say this did
your dad pass many years years ago or
not uh a few years ago but I feel like
your dad said I need my son to know that
I am proud of the man that he has become
and I cuz your dad shows me my symbol
for I'm sorry if I disappointed you or I
wasn't able to be the father that you
needed me to be do you understand that
yes and he says and for that I am sorry
when a soul says that they're sorry it
means that they had to relive their life
through our eyes they had to feel the
pain and the sorrow and the grief
of their choices actions and decisions
so know that your dad says I'm sorry and
always know that I am proud of the man
that you've become